as i've said uh this is a it's a big
deal for us
during the next three weeks including
this one we're going to be winding
things up here at tbs
and i'll be leaving the nightly format
that i've been doing for the last
28 years it's kind of unbelievable uh
my 11 years at tbs have been an absolute
joy they've been wonderful to us they've
let us do whatever we wanted
so we're going to be celebrating that
time with tbs
with some fun guests and some surprises
and guess what
we're also going to have real live
audiences
here at largo starting next week that's
right no more
cardboard cutouts no i i better move
yeah you get to come back up here
finally oh look what's it like up there
oh andy it's gonna blow your mind
it seems really nice anyway
uh it's gonna be a lot of fun we're
gonna have a blast think of it as a
two-week party which when i say it out
loud it sounds that sounds awful yeah it
does it sounds terrible
no one wants to go to a two-week party
anyway
we're going to be hungover dehydrated
and just hating each other
as you can imagine we're going to be
looking back at some of our favorite
things
we did here that's going to be part of
the show so i wanted
tonight we showed a piece last night
that was really fun
where i played the blues uh with some
first graders in chicago well tonight i
want to show you a piece
from one of our conan without borders
travel specials
it's from 2016 when i visited berlin
and andy and i learned a traditional
german
dance take a look
i am here with hans and simon is that
right which one are you
what france france what's wrong
and you're what are your your dietrich
you're simon simon
hans hans no france france
france i've had a lot of these
today i want to learn traditional
bavarian
dance you guys are experts we are you
are brothers
this is the what is that happening now
there's a vest here what's the best this
is like sort of a leprechaun thing
and then you have this lederhosen well
they're bonded shorts
what's going on with the socks and it's
called lofal
so that's german for pieces of socks
what's going on here
you've got two spoons in your pocket
what do you use those for
it hurts it's painful you
uh brought a musician with you
appreciate you leaving your cuckoo clock
to be here
right yeah you guys have worked together
before
yes we have
are you their father you're the [ __ ]
no one told me that what the hell
you just found out this is your father
suddenly i'm the german maury povich
i deserve a swig after that i think i
should begin
learn some dance we're going to learn
some what kind of dancing is it called
shoe platler
shoe platformer shoe platter you can't
learn the shoe platler
when you don't look like a bavarian
[Applause]
let us begin is
[Music]
loud
we're going to show you what you got
yourself into okay
do you think i could learn this but i'm
not like your sons you could have beat
me with a wooden stick to make me
dance they didn't want this this is what
they wanted they wanted to work with
computers
can do both
come on come on the guy's a monster for
you
one zero two three four
one two
i mean close enough closer please closer
stick you guys know what i'm talking
about so
one two three
exactly you knew where my hands were
don't be at these feet
where are they i think we know where
they are how come you have no accent
i don't understand what's happening here
first of all you are
i mean clearly you were carved out of a
sausage
and then you actually seemed like a
german guy
and this guy is like dude let's wax up
the board let's catch some rays
what's happened to him do you know billy
joel's the piano man
yeah i've heard about it that doesn't
work with sue bloodling
why don't you talk about that i'm just
asking if you knew billy joel's piano
later on work
[Music]
you started a little early no i just
gave you the chance to be in the right
spot
so conan come on does he ever admit he's
wrong no
one recommendation group therapy would
you think about it
with your two sons you're saying no
therapy
let's just keep with this insane scheme
of yours
to make your children dance and dance
and dance until the grave
[Music]
ready just one suggestion
don't spread your fingers like this we
know you have ten fingers
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
okay
[Applause]
pretty good know
you know i'm only in town for a couple
days i think this is pretty good
now i know not by this guy's standards
there are certainly a few things which
we could improve
yeah just hit us
[Applause]
you guys have been doing this since you
were fetuses i mean literally you were
born
your dad squeezed you into some leather
pants started hitting with wooden spoons
and making you live out this sick dream
and now you're ganging up on me
and i don't like it i want to bring in
someone who's the most german guy i know
could you come in here please the gates
boys
well this is the only place i can really
be in my natural state
uh without breaking up too many
marriages
[Laughter]
hear these this is like the reason you
put a bell on a cat
really so it can't catch too many birds
okay
ladies sneak in the bottom
because of your german roots i think
this is going to come very natural all
right
let's give it a try okay
[Applause]
you condone this yes brother on brother
ass play that's insane yeah
hold on
enjoyed watching that us slapping each
other's asses
like that it's part of the show oh yeah
everything's part of your little show
isn't it
i know what you've been doing and it
stops now
oh my god that guy man
that was unbelievable he was he was
perfect
he will not disappoint for a second